[Musique]
quant à martin bonjour bonjour merci
d'être là pour ce vip qui vous est
consacré vous êtes auteur vous êtes
comédiens et vous est même déjà venu
dans ce sursaut plateau c'est tout à
fait tout en souvenez oui je sais oui
c'est la deuxième fois que vous avez la
gentillesse de m'inviter voilà quoi
c'était quand je jouais avec mon
partenaire
olaf et jill oubliés de la fontaine à
booba à la royale factory il ya deux ans
vaud est donc là aujourd'hui c'est pour
présenter un livre exhaustif de la
fontaine abordant juste en dire deux
mots c'était un spectacle que vous aviez
écrit que vous jouiez à 2 qui était
destiné à tout le monde mais qui a
beaucoup plu je crois aux collégiens et
aux enseignants de français parce que
finalement vous remettiez un petit peu
en perspective la l'éternelle querelle
des anciens et des modernes
l'indépendant le rap des modernes
l'autre les classiques et la conclusion
de tout ça c'était quoi que la poésie
est partout
la conclusion c'est que
tous les goûts sont dans la nature et
qui en matière de goût il n'y a pas de
bonne réponse
exactement et du coup j'ai repris un
petit peu cet esprit-là dont le
justement à l'insécurité qu'il est
terminée mais donc vous êtes resté un
peu sur cette lancée
cet esprit là oui et pour ce livre qui
s'appelle figure de style de la fontaine
abouba elle a raconté mois alors il
l'idée c'est d'essayer de d'expliquer un
petit peu ce que sont les figures de
style qu'on a tous vu au lycée donc
métaphore allégories et c'est à travers
des exemples classiques d'auteurs
classiques et puis surtout c'est ça la
nouveauté du bouquin des exemples de des
extraits de chansons de rap à chaque
page on va trouver une figure de style
il y en a 60 dans le bouquin et sur
chaque page on va avoir une petite
définition et ensuite un exemple
d'auteurs classiques et ensuite une un
extrait de chanson de rap
et donc ça c'est le c'était toujours
dans le même esprit que le spectacle que
je joue et on essaye de réconcilier les
classiques les modernes
les poètes d'un autre temps et puis les
poètes contemporains que sont les
rappeurs en tout cas certains rappeurs
et voilà ça donne un joyeux mélange qui
j'espère aidera peut-être les jeunes et
les moins jeunes à comprendre ce que
c'est les figures de style et voir qu il
y en a tout autour de nous et comme vous
disiez tout à l'heure sur la poésie
c'est pareil on a tout autour de nous il
suffit
il suffit d'ouvrir les yeux et et on en
trouve d'accord alors là vous en avez
référence et 60,1 m qui sont donc donnés
par ordre alphabétique
est-ce que c'est soit sont là sont
censés être connu par des élèves de
première qui passent le bac alors
énorme oui c'est assez énorme moi j'ai
essayé de faire un petit livre assez
complet et puis surtout aussi assise
assez divertissant donc j'ai par exemple
j'ai rajouté aussi des jeux de mots qui
sera pas vraiment des figures de style
par rapport à la métaphore que tout le
monde dans à peu connaître pour le bac
de français
il ya par exemple le calembour ou le
détournement
d'ailleurs je précise que c'est pas
forcément des définitions de grammairien
je ne suis pas grammairien donc j'ai
essayé de synthétiser synthétiser un peu
certaines notions bizarre pardon
anacoluthe anadipp lose
enfin on découvre là pour le coup c'est
pas ma faute si elle s'appelle comme ça
si elles existent de nos maladies oui
exactement
le zew demain par exemple alors le zogma
à la tâche
parce que c'est la plus dure à peu près
a expliqué avant oui alors je vais juste
prendre un exemple qu'on connaît en tout
cas qu'on apprend souvent à l'école
c'est vêtue de lin blanc et de probité
candide
c'est un exemple de victor hugo et est
donc là l'adjectif vêtu va avoir deux
compléments donc de lin blanc c'est une
matière de textile en croissance propres
et de de probité dans ce cas là on est
dans sur le censeur abstrait et donc
elle fait d'avoir un mot comme ça qui a
deux compléments 1 ou figurer un os
propres
on est dans ce qu'on appelle un attelage
qui est un cas particulier du mal à
vraiment on est parti dans le truc le
plus technique
oui c'est très clair du coup comment est
ce que vous avez procédé parce que vous
avez des arts des artistes des auteurs
classiques qui remonte aux calendes
grecques ou presque alors grec nombre
parce que il ya que des auteurs
francophones dans le bouquin du coup un
des promus le premier auteur au sens
chronologique dans le bouquin c'est
guillaume de loris avec le roman de la
rose et on est au xiiie siècle et ça va
là 2018 qui est moins vieux et donc on
fait ce voyage à cheval sur sept siècles
avec tout un tas de classiques
évidemment il ya baudelaire il ya eu
goya rimbaud et puis à côté on va voir
90 rappeur j'ai essayé de varier les
plaisirs au maximum avec des rappeurs
old school c'est à dire qu'ils qui date
un petit peu de des années 90 où des
débuts des années 2000 dans un certain
style et et puis des rappeurs plus
récents qui continuent leur carrière
aujourd'hui
orelsan big flo et oli dans tout un tas
de styles divers parce que c'est ça
aussi l'idée du bouquin c'est de dire
qu'il n'ya pas un rap
en fait c'est un genre musical ça fait
en france ça fait une trentaine d'années
avait quand même
ouais et ça fait à peu près 15 ans que
c'est le genre musical le plus écoutées
en france donc il serait temps de lui
donner une sorte de c'est peut-être pas
une légitimité mais
de s'intéresser en fait à ce que c'est
et aux différents sous genre de rap kia
aux différents univers artistique kia
pour ne pas se contenter de dire c'est
une sous culture d'analphabètes
alors qu'il ya dix ans j'ai dit il ya
dix ans figurez vous qu'un intellectuel
français
a déclaré sur un plateau télé le rap est
une sous culture d'analphabètes alors
c'était eric zemmour pour ne pas le
nommer répondait alors je lui réponds en
préface du bouquin faisant une petite
analyse de cette figure de style puisque
c'est une hyperbole 1 il est dans une
figure d'exagération total donc pour le
détail de ma réponse vous pouvez
regarder dans le livre mais en tout cas
c'était un petit clin d'oeil à eric
zemmour et puis à pas mal de gens qui
ont une image assez superficielle du rap
et bien sûr mais en fait c'était mon cas
aussi avant c'est à dire que je prenais
le tout venant qui passait à la radio
et effectivement si on se contente de ce
qui passe vraiment le meilleur
exactement ce n'est pas forcément le
meilleur qui surnage
et ça c'est vrai pour la chanson
française en général ferme pour l'europe
comme jeu comme je le dis dans la ma
petite lettre à eric zemmour
c'est pas parce que
je n'aime pas christophe maé que je vais
mettre à cracher sur toute la chanson
française d'hier christophe maé ne
représente pas la chanson française
c'est pareil pour booba ne représente
pas le rap ou le rap francophone
voilà donc c'est juste une invitation à
gratter un petit peu sous la surface
et puis je suis sûr que tout le monde il
trouvera quelques quelques petites
fleurs des choses qu'il est qui qui les
feront sourire d'autres qui trouveront
jolie d'autres malicieuse et les coûts
ces pépites là elle nous montre que
finalement pas d'encre et que verlan sas
a apporté beaucoup au langage
vocabulaire sas a ouvert des possibles
par rapport à la versification bas tout
à fait ouais déjà dans le rap alors il y
avait aussi un écrivain qui dans les
années 90 quand on tombé sur le dos de
dén tm iam etc qui en plus sont des
groupes qui est qui écrivait de manière
assez classique qui avait qui respecte
et une versification assez classique
entre guillemets il a dit mais enfin il
faut quand même considérer que le rap
mais remet sur le devant de la scène
quelque chose qui est antique c'est la
voix et rien que ça cette manière de
scander sur un rythme
bah je sais pas ça peut faire penser à
aux élèves grecs qui scandait comme ça
des dévers d'homère il ya 2500 ans et
c'est vrai qu'il ya déjà ce retour aux
sources par la voix c'est ça que moi je
trouve hyper intéressant dans le rap
c'est que chaque rappeur va voir son
voix salsa bois par ce flot son flot le
flou c'est une composante
ces composés de la voix le grain de la
voix et puis surtout la manière de poser
le terme sur le rythme donc la prosodie
houleux comme on dirait à l'école et et
la manière d'articuler ça sur la musique
et donc il ya des rappeurs qui sont
assez virtuose là dedans en france aux
états unis est bon alors ça pour le coup
dans mon livre on se rendra pas compte
parce que c'est par écrit c'est pour ça
que je précise à la fin que c'est une
musique qu'il faut écouter et qui a une
playlist avec les textes qui sont
évoqués dans le bouquin qui est
disponible sur sur internet et lire à
haute voix ce livre on peut lire à haute
voix mais d'une façon pour reproduire le
flou d'un rappeur ça va peut-être être
difficile mais comme comme vous disiez
ouais il ya après il ya une grosse
innovation aussi c'est le verlan parce
que ça permet de
changez l'accent tonique sur un mot ça
permet de multiplier les mots aussi
puisque par exemple si on prend cité
basse à peu se mettre à l'envers t 6
août est ce ça ça multiplie les rimes
donc pour un poète qui est limité dans
son vocabulaire et dans son ombre de rim
c'est une richesse supplémentaire et
puis ça crée des choses surprenantes
c'est ça qui est bien avec le rap c'est
qu'ils vont repousser les limites
classiques de la de la poésie c'est là
bercy fille dans l'invention permanente
ils disent ils sont bien pas avec les
règles utilisant leurs propres règles il
est créé voilà et il sait et nommé
depuis 30 ans pourrait dire que on peut
on peut dire que c'est un genre qui
continue à innover
si on prend la trappe par exemple qui
sait qu'un genre de rap qui marche bien
depuis
depuis quelques semaines la trappe c'est
un rythme assez assez binaire assez
saccadée
moi je suis pas très fan mais ça peut
être une contrainte qui pousse comme
c'est un nombre de syllabes limité à
avoir un concentré de un concentré dans
l'écriture et par exemple je tombais sur
une chanson de 2 sur le nouvel album de
ces scènes qui est génial il arrive avec
ce petit nombre de syllabes ce rythme
assez saccadée à faire quelque chose de
très bien un exemple l'alleud
non non je vais me contenter de dire
regardez dans le bouquin comme ça ça
m'évite de plonger dans ma mémoire
bon la fontaine doit être content
finalement tawil est lui qui voulait de
la nouveauté de la gaieté oui c'est une
de ces mantras mai
je sais pas je ne sais pas ça va être un
petit peu compliqué de lui poser la
question mais voilà en tout cas ce qui
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que la
fontaine aujourd'hui on le voit comme un
classique
d'ailleurs il est offert à tous les
élèves de seine et ben voilà c'est une
très bonne idée et il est libre
exactement c'est ce que j'ai l'elysée
d'alexandre un sas et ça c'était ça
c'était hugo qui a dit ça cela dit ça au
19e siècle s'est disloqué second rang ni
et d'alexandre r mais il faut dire
quelque chose c'est que déjà deux
siècles avant la fontaine avait fait
sauter les règles et les verrous
classique puisque il écrivait en vers
libres
ça veut dire quoi c'est cher que au lieu
de le faire alexandre un alexandrin
alexandrins c'est 12,6 l'appui 5 puis 3
en fonction du rythme donc il ya du flou
à l'écrit en fait la pizza c'est ça que
moi j'encourage tout le monde passant le
bac de français ou non à lire ce livre
on apprend plein de choses c'est très
diversifié en diversifiant non on essaye
c'est un néologisme c'est un néologisme
je sais plus qui les connaît la page
mais ahoua mots valises plus tôt et vous
avez été lauréat d'un concours de poésie
de la ratp alors lauréats non mais gt gt
dont j'étais dans les finalistes de 10
dans les noms dans les sons dont les
sons or je me trompe avec les filles
c'est pas grave
ah non alors je le connais par coeur
n'ont clairement pas non mais c'était un
poème c'est un poème sur le sur le métro
bah je crois qu'il est sur mon blog sur
place ça vous intéresse
on peut l'acheter eh bien il est
disponible sur une grande plate-forme
plateforme e-commerce qui commence par
un a et qui finit par ma zone oui je ne
divulguerai absolument pas le nom de
cette plateforme et puis je dis ça
exactement le prix d'un kebab avec tout
ce qu'il ya dedans c'est ça la tomate
oignon comme dirait booba dans une salle
il ya tout ce qui faut il ya des
exercices corrigés à la fin si vous
voulez vous entraîner à repérer les
figures de style il ya une avalanche de
punchlines bonus à la fin du livre une
petite centaine avec des petites des
petites couronnes de fleurs comme ça que
j'ai trouvé à gauche et à droite et
épique et il y en a encore que je
continue à alimenter sur internet et
bientôt un autre livre sur l'histoire
géo a pas un livre
peut-être y aura un livre après mais un
spectacle mais pour l'instant tout est
brûlé chantier mais c'est pas ok déjà
celui-là très bien un grand merci va
notamment à merci beaucoup à vous et à
très vite j'espère a très vite merci
beaucoup
[Musique]